was bedroht das überleben der menschheit
am meisten ein internationaler atomkrieg
der klimawandel eine künstliche
intelligenz die ein bewusstsein erlangt
und intelligenter wird als jeder mensch
all das könnte für das leben auf der
erde katastrophal seien aber neben all
diesen spektakulären bedrohungen die auf
uns lauern gibt es auch eine die sich
still und heimlich anbahnt eine
bedrohung die wir jeden tag selber mit
heranzüchten multiresistente bakterien
[Musik]
bakterien sind das kleinste dass wir
noch als leben bezeichnen
und sie sind überall alleine in deinem
körper befinden sich jetzt gerade circa
40 billionen bakterien mehr als du
menschliche körperzellen hast das ist
aber kein problem denn die meisten
bakterien sind haben lust und helfen
deinen körper sogar richtig zu
funktionieren
es gibt aber auch bakterien die in
deinem körper eindringen sich schnell
vermehren und dich töten können
im vierzehnten jahrhundert sorgte die
pest für 25 millionen tote jeder dritte
mensch in europa fiel damals den
sogenannten schwarzen tod zum opfer bis
heute stellen sogenannte pandemien das
sind also länder oder sogar kontinente
übergreifende ausbreitung von
krankheiten eine große gefahr für uns
dar
vor allem da wir menschen heutzutage
noch enger in städten zusammen leben
aber wir haben ja auch dazu gelernt
hygienische gegenmaßnahmen wie zum
beispiel händewaschen gehören inzwischen
zum absoluten standard und wenn doch mal
etwas passieren sollte haben wir ja
arzneimittel seit 1941 das erste mal
penizillin chemisch hergestellt werden
konnte sind wir in der lage gefährliche
infektionskrankheiten zu behandeln
medizin gehört zu den antibiotika diese
arzneistoffe töten entweder
bakterienzellen ab oder sie hemmen die
vermehrung der bakterien
diese eigenschaften machen antibiotika
zu einer wahren wunderwaffe im kampf
gegen bakterielle infektionskrankheiten
sie sind so wirksam dass sie zu den
weltweit am häufigsten verschriebenen
medikamenten gehören und mit 13 prozent
den größten marktanteil besitzen
zusammen mit impfungen haben antibiotika
die medizin revolutioniert und millionen
von menschenleben gerettet
leider können antibiotika aber auch für
probleme sorgen
immer wieder entwickeln bakterien durch
zufall eigenschaften die sie gegen ein
oder mehrere antibiotika resistent
machen
diese genetischen veränderungen sind
natürlich durch die einwirkung von
antibiotika werden die empfindlichen und
sensitiven bakterien beseitigt
dadurch aber haben die resistenten
bakterien nun mehr platz für die
vermehrung das antibiotikum ist gegen
diese hilflos und begünstigt eine
vermehrung und ausbreitung der
resistenten
ja das passiert ironischerweise häufig
in krankenhäusern die ja besonders
sauber gehalten und sogar antibakteriell
behandelt werden
diese super reinen konditionen sorgen
dafür dass die wenigen bakterien die die
krankenhausbehandlung überleben
plötzlich eine menge nährstoffe zur
verfügung haben und sich schnell
ausbreiten können besonders
multiresistente bakterien also jene die
gegen gleich mehrere antibiotika
resistent sind können zum problem werden
bisher hatten wir auch in brenzligen
situationen immer noch ein ass im ärmel
reserve antibiotika wie zum beispiel
ciprofloxacin ein anderes reserve
antibiotikum ist call ist ihm dieses
wurde lange zeit kaum verwendet da ist
die nieren angreift das macht es zu
einer perfekten notlösung falls alle
stricke reißen und normale antibiotika
nicht weiterhelfen
um die wirkung von kristin nicht zu
mindern darf es aber nur unter strengen
bedingungen und nur im notfall
eingesetzt werden
doch 2015 fanden forscher bakterien die
selbst gegen dieses reserve antibiotikum
resistent waren der grund in china wurde
es jahrelang ins futter von schweinen
gemischt um dort die verbreitung von
krankheiten zu vermeiden
es entwickelten sich resistenzen die von
den schweinen auf den menschen
übertragen wurden
ein solcher multiresistenter erreger
stellt ein riesiges problem für uns da
weil wir kaum möglichkeiten hätten ihn
aufzuhalten
es war werden ständig neue formen von
antibiotika entwickelt und auf den markt
gebracht und mit den resistenten
erregern schritt zu halten aber eine
pandemie könnte in unserer heutigen
globalisierten welt innerhalb von
wenigen wochen den ganzen globus
umspannen und millionen von
menschenleben kosten
was wir tun können um so eine
katastrophe zu verhindern
nun nicht so viele antibiotika verwenden
je häufiger wir ein mittel einsetzen
desto mehr erreger haben die möglichkeit
eine resistenz zu entwickeln und desto
schwächer wird dieses mittel
deswegen ist es sehr wichtig dass
antibiotika nur verschrieben werden wenn
es wirklich notwendig ist
diese medikamente sind ein absolutes
wunder werk unserer modernen
gesellschaft und dienen nicht dazu einem
normalen schnupfen entgegenzuwirken
schnupfen und auch gruppe übrigens
werden von viren ausgelöst und gegen
viren
sind antibiotika sowieso absolut nutzlos
das ist so als würde man einen riss im
bildschirm des smartphones mit einem
software-update reparieren wollen
es ist einfach der falsche ansatz der
behandlung man könnte meinen dass gerade
ärzte wüssten wie gefährlich es ist so
viel antibiotika zu verschreiben
aber erstaunlicherweise ist genau das
gegenteil der fall und viele ärzte
verschreiben auch bei kleinigkeiten
antibiotika teilweise weil es einfach
ist und teilweise weil die patienten das
fordern wenn ihr arzt euch also das
nächste mal ein antibiotikum verschreibt
fragt lieber noch mal nach ob das
wirklich nötig ist oder ob man nicht
eine andere behandlung ohne antibiotikum
ausprobieren könnte dieses video
entstand in kooperation mit dem projekt
arena das im kontext der deutschen
antibiotikaresistenz strategie der
bundesregierung durchgeführt wird wenn
ihr noch fragen zum thema antibiotic
gehabt dann kann ich euch die arena
website nur ans herz legen dort findet
ihr viele viele antworten rund ums thema
und ansonsten wenn ihr noch andere
fragen habt so gar nicht mehr unten in
den kommentaren was zu schreiben ich
antworte ich da gerne ansonsten vielen
dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt neugierig